they're gonna be pushing 90 in some
places for the next several days in
southern california so i don't know how
fun that's going to be for the folks who
live down there but i bet there's a lot
of people going to be at the beach it's
going to be good beach weather we'll
talk about that and heat advisories for
southern california well we've had a few
a few little breezes but boy do we have
beautiful skies now this is a little
disturbance kind of moving up and over
this ridge of high pressure it's
bringing a few clouds uh kind of biased
they're not going to hang out all day
they're not going to be with us all that
long but they will stir up a little wind
we've had some breezes in the north end
of town from downtown through north las
vegas and so that's been keeping temps
in the 50s but just about everybody else
has found 40s and these are even above
normal 43 is the normal morning low we
always hit our morning low right at
daybreak so sunrise is just a little bit
after 6 30. a little breeze out at red
rock too temperatures are mild there at
46 with a little bit of wind 35 at
indian springs kind of cool there 45 and
perhaps 38 in mesquite and we've got 50s
boulder city to search light in even 60s
in laughlin this morning with 20s up
there in caliani and ely so yesterday 73
our normal high is 62. for today in the
next several days and instead we're
looking at 74.
that much closer to the record high of
78 for today's date and that was just
back in 2018. 6 34 is the sunrise and 5
18 the sunset wow nice we're getting
that daylight lasting a little longer
all right so the west pretty protected
we'll look at the satellite picture
there in a moment a few showers snow
showers across the great lakes
cincinnati another cool day today highs
though not bad in the upper 40s and low
50s so i'm sure they'd rather be in
southern california and rain across the
southeast coast from florida stretched
out just barely along the coast of the
carolinas it's starting to pull away out
to the atlantic today so sunny skies
except here we have those high clouds
see how they fall apart that's the
disturbance kind of spilling across the
great basin that ridge of high pressure
also creating those offshore winds like
the santa ana pattern that southern
california gets usually in the fall
months but boy they've got it today and
wind advisories and heat advisories for
these areas of blue and orange from
today all the way until sunday evening
that's going to drive temperatures into
the upper 80s to near 90 degrees in many
areas of southern california 74 today
can't complain about that northeast
breezes 15 maybe 20 miles an hour at
times and into tonight that system is
gone and we're quiet still very warm mid
70s on friday our warmest day but still
very warm for valentine's day on monday
roses and chocolates keep them out of
the warm sun
and then a chance of sprinkles and
cooler on tuesday back to low 60s by
wednesday